♪ ♪
>> WELCOME TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY.
I AM DAN BONGINO IN TONIGHT FOR
SEAN.
JOE BIDEN AND THE EXTREME
DEMOCRATS ARE FAILING AT THE
BORDER, FEELING ABROAD, AND
FAILING TO DELIVER FOR
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS ALL
ACROSS THIS GREAT COUNTRY AND
THE WORST PART IS THEY ARE
DOUBLING DOWN IN THIS RECKLESS
RADICAL IRRESPONSIBLE SOCIALIST
AGENDA EVERY SINGLE CHANCE THEY
GET.
FOR EXAMPLE, JOE BIDEN'S
UNVEILING OF WHOPPING
$6 TRILLION BUDGET PROPOSAL, THE
LARGEST IN U.S. HISTORY THAT
WOULD VASTLY EXPAND THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF THE ALREADY BLOATED
GOVERNMENT AND YOUR ROLE IN
MANAGING YOUR EVERYDAY LIFE.
ACCORDING TO ESTIMATES, IT WOULD
PUT THE BUDGET DEFICIT AT
1.3 TRILLION PER YEAR FOR THE
NEXT DECADE.
AND WOULD PUT US ON A PATH TO
HAVING THE HIGHEST INTERNATIONAL
DEBT AS A PROPORTION OF THE
ECONOMY SO DON'T BE FOOLED BY
THE POLITICAL PLATITUDES, THEY
ARE CHEAP NONSENSE TALKING
POINTS AND FAR LEFT FANTASIES.
WHAT HE IS DOING IS MORTGAGING
OUR FUTURE AND CREATING A
PERFECT STORM FOR FISCAL CHAOS
FOR CURRENT AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
WHAT JOE BIDEN IS DOING RIGHT
NOW IS NOT SMART, NOT EVEN SAINT
AND CERTAINLY NOT SUSTAINABLE.
IT'S A BIG GOVERNMENT BINGE OF
MORE TAXES, MORE DEBT, MORE
SPENDING AND GUARANTEED TURMOIL.
DON'T BUY THE LIES THAT THESE
CHILEANS WILL BE PAID BY THE
SO-CALLED RICH, DO THE MATH,
IT'S COMMON SENSE.
IN THE END, THIS WILL BE PAID
FOR BY YOU, WORKING-CLASS DIRT
UNDER THE FINGERNAILS WHO WORK
FOR A LIVING ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AND WHAT ABOUT INFLATION?
RISING COSTS AT THE GAS PUMP AND
AT GROCERY STORES, GOING TO HAVE
TO PAY FOR THAT TOO BUT THE
DESTRUCTIVE DEMOCRATIC AGENDA
DOESN'T STOP THERE.
BECAUSE DESPITE THE CRISIS AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, THE BUDGET
LEAVES THE BUDGET FLAT.
THE ONE THING WE SHOULD BE
DEVOTING MORE RESOURCES TO IS
THE ONE ITEM HE DECIDED TO LEAVE
OUT, BUT THEY CONTINUE TO PLAY
DEFENSE FOR JOE ON EVERY TERM
CONTINUE TO ACT AS AN ARM OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY INSTEAD OF
FOCUSING ON BIDEN'S FAILURES AND
HIS TOTAL, COMPLETE INABILITY TO
LEAD.
DON'T BELIEVE ME?
LOOK AT THIS EMBARRASSING FIASCO
THIS WEEK WHEN THEY ASKED SLEEPY
ABOUT HIS ICE CREAM, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WHY DID YOU
SERVE?
>> CHOCOLATE CHOCOLATE CHIP.
>> WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO
REPUBLICANS PREPARED TO BLOCK
THE JANUARY 6 COMMISSIO